before we talk about science we'd like
to give a big shout out
to our sponsors at vocal
if a tree falls in the forest and no one
is around to hear it
does it make a sound according to
quantum theorists
that tree might not even exist until
it's observed
so is our world just
an illusion why do some
physicists believe that physical matter
isn't real what scientific experiments
have
changed our view of reality
and could everything we see
just be a hallucination
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the world is only your illusion
the great philosopher rene descartes
came to the profound conclusion that
i think therefore i am he was searching
for a universal truth that
couldn't be disputed and the act of
thinking was
undeniable proof of his existence
yet our understanding of existence and
reality
are still evolving in the worlds of
quantum physics and
neuroscience there are different
theories about
what reality is so
what is reality if we dive deep into the
quantum realm
matter is made up of subatomic particles
these particles including protons
neutrons and electrons
are in a state of flux until they're
observed
in fact at the quantum level they may
not even look like
particles at all you could think of them
as a cloud of probabilities
this concept is known as superposition
meaning a particle exists
in several possible positions until they
are measured
the idea of superposition was famously
observed in the double slit experiment
by physicist thomas young in 1801. when
we shine a beam of light through one
slit
it produces a predictable line of light
but
when another slit is added something
kind of spooky happens
instead of two lines of light we see
several
the photons seem to act like a wave
as if they were rippling through the
slits and bouncing off each other in
different directions
this interference pattern led scientists
to believe that
matter could act as both particles and
waves
that was a profound idea that changed
the world of physics forever
so if things only exist when they're
observed
would black holes still exist if we
hadn't measured their x-rays
some physicists like max tegmark believe
that
black holes and everything we perceive
to be real
is simply mathematical information this
idea
is known as information realism
in the world of philosophy this idea of
reality being
a product of our observation is known as
phenomenalism
it states that anything we experience is
simply sensory data in our minds as if
life itself is virtual reality without
the silly glasses
if scientists were able to send signals
to a living brain
in a vat simulating all the senses could
we trick the brain to believe it's in a
human body somewhere and
experiencing reality maybe we could
reprogram our ideas
at the neural level just imagine being
able to fly
anywhere you want drive fancy cars dodge
bullets and
live forever your pleasure your
achievements and
your level of success would only be
limited by your ability
to imagine them some cognitive
neuroscientists including
professor anil seth suggest that our
brains are hallucinating reality all the
time
have you ever had a dream that felt so
real that you jolted awake feeling
disoriented
like that one night when i thought i was
stuck in a how to survive episode
well our nightmares and our perceptions
of reality
are both processed in our brain's visual
cortex
this is why it can be hard to tell the
difference between them
you know maybe you could start a diary
or a dream journal
or a video blog and keep track of all
your brain stories
for content creators vocal is a great
platform for all kinds of stories
it's an amazing community of bloggers
podcasters
youtubers and more do you have a science
themed youtube channel like
we do well you can promote and monetize
your content
on vocal.media to reach a whole new
audience
vocal hosts weekly challenges with
chances to win
cash prizes and more with over 30
different topic based communities
there's something for everyone
even us we've been posting our what if
stories on vocal as well
so check out the link below to learn
more
even though we can't exactly be sure
what
is real with rapid advancements in the
world of physics and neuroscience
we're getting closer to understanding
the complexities of reality
maybe we'll crack the code someday
speaking of coding
could it be possible that we're just
characters in
some sort of computer simulation
i mean video game graphics are looking
pretty real these days
on that note computer load what if
sequence
okay peter that's a story
for another what if
[Music]
you